en españa nunca habían nacido tan pocos
niños como ahora cada mujer tiene de
media 12 niños el índice de fecundidad
más bajo de europa lejos de asegurar la
renovación de la población ese fenómeno
se puede comprobar en esta guardería
madrileña
no permite el milo
gracias
a lo largo de sus 15 años de experiencia
joaquín ha comprobado que los padres
tienen menos hijos pues sentimos que la
familia con tener un hijo o dos hijos a
veces tres pero muy pocos casos pero ya
desde hace años primera explicación la
situación laboral en españa es inestable
y los jóvenes tienen hijos más tarde
aproximadamente te encontrabas familias
que podían tener un hijo con 30 con 32
contra el de 5 o con 27 ahora esto es
mucho más
mucho más difícil ahora nos encontramos
que la mayoría de las familias tienen un
hijo a partir de los 35
las autoridades de la comunidad de
madrid están preocupadas por la caída de
los nacimientos y las consecuencias para
el país no va a haber gente que pague
las pensiones de las personas mayores en
el futuro aparte de que una población
joven es necesario para que el país sea
más dinámico la institución ya tiene un
papel un plan de natalidad ambicioso que
comenzará a funcionar el año próximo
estamos trabajando en ello una medida
estrella que es dar a las mujeres menos
de 30 años desde los 5 meses de embarazo
y durante dos años una ayuda de 500
euros 14 mil 500 al año para ayudarles a
que si quieren tener más hijos los
tengan y podamos contribuir
económicamente a lo que significa
económicamente un hijo debería ser el
gobierno en españa quien adoptará este
tipo de medidas pero de momento no lo ha
hecho
en el instituto nacional de estadística
antonio es el encargado de analizar la
demografía
realmente si seguimos las trayectorias
de los últimos 10 años en españa la
fecundidad ha ido disminuyendo de manera
casi continua casi continua en torno a
un 4 un 5% cada año una situación
hipotética de un país que cierra sus
fronteras por completo españa ahora
mismo perdería en torno a 100 mil
personas al año
según él españa necesita una política de
natalidad nacional a largo plazo pero la
única solución para actuar rápido es la
inmigración si estrictamente lo que nos
preocupa es que la población de un país
crezca
es mucho más sencillo que crezca por la
inmigración que crezca por la natalidad
por una cuestión numérica
el gobierno español ha declarado que
acogerá cada año 250 mil inmigrantes
para sostener la economía el papel de
los inmigrantes se ha vuelto
imprescindible en la hostelería trabajo
doméstico y construcción donde la mano
de obra cada vez es más escasa
[Música]
la empresa de construcción
horus es una de las que contrata a mano
de obra extranjera para paliar el
déficit de personal en españa se están
necesitando 700 mil obreros tenemos
mucho personal extranjero de europa del
este de américa latina y bueno gracias a
ellos hay personas muy cualificados muy
formado pues estamos validando esa falta
de personal que tenemos aquí en españa
de determinados gremios
según un estudio de comisiones obreras
los inmigrantes ocupan trabajos y
puestos que la población nacional no
desea
cuánto tiempo llevas aquí en españa
del 94 pero aún ver esto pero tengo
varios amigos que quieren venir para
aquí para tratar del producto de reforma
de todo pero ahora nos controlan los
colombianos de todo
las compañías españolas también están
contratando cada vez más a latinos
cualificados para completar puestos de
trabajo es el caso de sofía soy de
montevideo uruguay y hace 3 años que
trabajo en españa'
estando empleada en una empresa latina
de tecnología una compañía española
decidió reclutar la y traerla en el país
la escasez de personal capacitado en
este sector también se ha agudizado
escribieron por linkedin de una empresa
que bueno española que quería abrir
digamos sus servicios en latinoamérica y
estaban buscando específicamente una
persona que conociese muchísimo al
mercado argentino y uruguayo con el que
yo tenía experiencia creo que hay una
tendencia de que se están contratando
más latinoamericanos en europa bueno
desde que estoy aquí la verdad que
conocí muchísima gente que está la misma
situación que yo
si no se agilizan las políticas para
incentivar nacimientos a la larga el
país tendrá más necesidad de aceptar
extranjeros para que sobreviva la
economía